i want to change tack a little bit if
you don't mind francis
just to go back to an issue that you
briefly mentioned which is mass
immigration
and the reason i want to bring it up is
that i remember watching you on question
time
and you you called it a catastrophe and
the the four other panelists would
essentially not let you speak
so uh this is the opposite of what we do
here so you've called a catastrophe
why is it a catastrophe and you've got
you plenty of time because of the scale
of it
you can't the immigration is is is
is good generally both for the people
who do it and for the countries which
accept it
provided that there's a chance to
integrate when i
began in politics long ago when i was a
revolutionary socialist
the thing that we used to talk about was
uh that we were really really against
was what we call racialism in those days
racial discrimination it's just it's
distinct in an important way from the
word racism that people use now
and one of the things that we very much
called for was integration
and integration is perfectly possible if
someone comes here
as a as an individual and and
wants to bring up his children or uh
start
a family or and go to work and all the
things that people do they come
from other countries usually to improve
themselves then
in time they will learn the language
they'll learn the customs they'll learn
the law
they will become pretty much
british and no one will
no one will get in their way in in doing
so if huge numbers of people come
simultaneously then that process is
impossible
what will happen is that people will
gather in areas they won't integrate
they will form solitudes with their
backs turned upon each other
and you will get especially if the state
as it does now encourages
multiculturalism you will get a society
where
large parts of so you take a city like
bradford for instance
large parts of the population never meet
other parts of the population except
uh maybe in the city center crossing in
the crossing the radar and shots but not
in any
realistically integratory way so mass
immigration
is is damaging because it prevents
integration
it's also damaging because few
immigrants
are rich they will tend to come and live
in the poorer areas of cities
and they will therefore be
experienced most of all by the poorest
people who are
not terribly interested in the fact that
there's a funky new restaurant around
the corner or that you can hire nanny as
cheap
what they see is they see in some cases
competition uh
for their jobs and i've often thought by
the way that if there were
if if polish and romanian and bulgarian
and other migrants this country
could compete for the jobs of television
uh commentators and guardian
uh leader writers there would be a lot
more concern about
this country than there is but they
don't it's not that it's it's in other
areas of society where
where it happens and of course also they
put pressure on the housing and on the
on the schools and on the medical
services which means and the transport
which means that
everybody is slightly worse off
in a way which they reside and the other
thing is of course that people don't
feel at home in their own areas
and it's all very well to laugh and mock
at that but i
really don't see how you can't view it
as quite a big problem especially if
you're an old person
living alone or where your children have
gone in a small house in a
poor area of town to find bit by bit
that the area in which you grew up
is no longer recognizable to you i think
that's a serious problem it hurts people
and it's it's not fascist
to be sympathetic towards it or to think
that it would probably be wise to avoid
it
and would you blame globalization for
this or is it do you think is there a
particular
politician i think there is a i think
there
are traces of a policy uh in the famous
uh
memorandum that andrew neither is
associated with
uh which i haven't to hand so i can't
quote from it but there seemed to be a
suggestion in what had come out of new
labour that
period of heightened blarism uh that
they actually
saw large-scale immigration as a way
of to rub the rights notes and rubbing
the rights for those in diversity but i
think even more than that i think they
didn't
the new labour people i regard them as
euro communists uh revolutionaries
they didn't like britain as it was in
the 1980s or before then
and they wanted to change it
irreversibly and i think they may well
have seen large-scale immigration as a
way of doing that
and that's
that is after all what happened there's
also another thing
governments from both major parties i
think have decided that they want
to turn this into a low-wage economy so
high levels of employment
but low levels of wages as opposed to
what it was before an economy whether
whether
there was high high productivity
comparatively high prices in
comparatively high wages
that's an economic decision that
requires if it's to work
a a large amount of of extra labor
coming into the country and that means
immigration i think they've actually
been
although they make speeches saying we're
going to get it under control one day
and bring it down to whatever level it
is per year
i think actually what they've had in
mind and what their economic
economic advisers have told them is that
they should they should
if not actually actively encouraged
certainly be perfectly happy to accept
a fairly constantly high level of of
migration of young men and women who
will
who will fill these low-wage jobs which
they do
but there's a very easy way to shut down
that debate is that somebody voices your
opinions and i'm here listening to them
go well this is all perfectly reasonable
is from the other person to shout well
you're racist you're resentful
and they do but i can't the only the
only answer i can give you to that is
that you'd have to provide some sort of
uh some sort of justification for making
the claim as i say i used to be a
revolution
revolutionary socialist the best thing
about the far left in this country
always was its absolute opposition to
racial bigotry
uh it's a it's a point that i've i've
never diverged from in all my changes of
political position since then i've
never changed my view racial bigotry is
disgusting
and i'm against it if you don't like it
i think
one of the things you might need to do
is to consider whether large-scale
immigration actually makes
racial bigotry more or less likely i
suspect that it can make it more likely